wait you did something special with your  daughters when you interest you about  marry and I thought this was the  sweetest thing ever  well they got married yeah Patricia  doesn't have children yes they got  married they exchanged rings and said  vows to each other because I told them  if something happens to me you got to  take care of the Queen you know you got  to take care of miss Yearwood and it was  great it was the dinner we were out to  dinner all three of them it was a really  tight conversation I'm nervous and I  finally woke up the courage to say to  get married and they were all fine with  I said but you got to take care of her  and I'm waiting for something  intelligent to come back and it was the  youngest ally that said we got your back  bra strap I will not stop talking until  you subscribe to my YouTube channel  that's right and I could talk a lot  seriously not gonna stop yep still here  not going anywhere I see you don't walk  away from this